this is Kimberly Leonard in the Sky News
Daily
more twists in the BBC story today it's
another claim from another individual
about the same presenter and the BBC
director General has given more detail
about the original allegation and how
the corporation has responded so loads
to catch up on
let's start with the latest development
first reported by BBC News Sadia
Chowdhury has been on this for Sky News
she's outside BBC headquarters in
central London hi Sadia so what are the
new claims
I can believe these are fresh
allegations being reported by the BBC
they say that a young person has told
BBC news that they felt threatened by
the BBC presenter who is at the center
of this story with the Sun newspaper a
reminder that this presenter is already
part of this story where a mother has
alleged the Sun newspaper that her child
when they were 17 sent explicit messages
to this presenter in exchange for money
now this new allegation where this
individual who is in their early 20s
says they were first contacted by this
male presenter on a dating app they say
they were put under pressure to meet up
but never did and then they have spoken
to BBC News and said that they have no
connection to that first set of
allegations the first person who brought
those allegations in the sun story but
they said that they were scared by the
power that this presenter had over them
that when they said to the presenter
that they know who they are and they may
go public with their name that they
received menacing messages from them
very threatening messages so it's very
serious and it adds to this story where
we've already heard very significant and
serious and potentially criminal
allegations against this presenter and
BBC News has been very clear how it has
verified this hasn't it so they've seen
the messages yes the BBC
um is obviously separate to this BBC
News uh doing this reporting and say
that they've spoken to this person that
would mean that they would have verified
their identity that's a standard
procedure that all journalists do when
we speak to anyone but not only that but
they've also seen these messages
themselves and they've also checked that
that phone number matches that of the
presenter so lots of verification done
there a bit of investigating from BBC
journalists themselves and certainly
some people might say much quicker than
the BBC's and corporate investigative
team had done and said it just finally
there has still been no word from the
presenter on this new claim no there
hasn't there wasn't uh with the first
set of claims there hasn't been from
this claim either we know that the BBC
News has contacted the presenter
directly and through his lawyer and
they've said that they've received no
response to the latest allegations and a
reminder we still don't know who this
presenter is there's no way for us at
Sky News to do any of our own digging on
these uh claims but BBC News say they've
contacted the presenter and they've had
no response back from them
okay Sadia thank you so much
so that's Sadia but before that
development was being reported attention
was on the BBC director General Tim
Davey as journalists asked him questions
about these claims our home editor Jason
Farrell was one of them and he's been
telling me about the BBC's timeline of
events
so first of all he said that there was a
contact made with the BBC someone
actually went to the BBC building on the
18th of May they then got in contact
with um the services of the BBC to deal
with complaints on the 19th of May and
there was a there was a phone
conversation which we now when I was a
was a 29 minute uh phone conversation
detailing uh the allegations and then
that was passed through to the corporate
investigations team who deemed it as
serious but not criminal but I'll come
back to that in a minute so though then
what happens is they say they get lots
of these complaints they have to verify
them so they then send an email back to
the complainant and they said they
didn't get a response to that and and
then there's a delay until June the 6th
I still haven't had a response and they
make a phone call but they say that
phone call didn't connect and then
subsequent to that they say that the
investigation remained open but they
didn't actually make any further
attempts to make contact with the
complainant what we also know is that
they didn't contact the person who had
been complained about so at this stage
it's pretty much left open with nothing
happening
that's back in me and that's back in May
through June and then we get to July the
6th so a month literally after that
phone call that didn't connect comes the
the sun allegations and at this point on
the seventh they do speak to the
presenter they do reach out to the
complainant the complainant then
provides them with further information
and they go to the police and then the
police after that meeting say they're
not launching an investigation but they
are scoping this out to get gather
further information to see if there is
evidence of a crime and at that point
because there is police involvement the
BBC have to pause their investigation
and you asked about the difference
between the May claims and the latest
claims so what interests me and I think
what interests a lot of people is
what was it in the Sun article that was
different to the complaint on the 19th
of May uh why why was it not assessed as
criminal uh then but it was afterwards
why was there a suspension after the Sun
article but not a spent a suspension
before so I put that to the directory
General who essentially said that the
assessors had looked at it and that they
had decided it was very serious
but that they thought that there wasn't
evidence of criminality and I think the
problem with that response is that it
doesn't just give us that extra detail
that we might have wanted because let's
not forget that the BBC are being
accused by the family of lying about
this so when the BBC produced their
statement on the weekend saying that
there was new information in the sun of
a different nature the family responded
to that saying that's a lie the family
said we told you about things that you
could have worked out were criminal and
I think we can be pretty clear what we
mean by that so what the family had had
said to the Sun newspaper is that
although the individual is now 20 years
old that this dated back three years and
the allegations were that the presenter
paid a lot of money for explicit
photographs and if that person was 17 at
the time that would have been a criminal
offense because they cannot consent to
that kind of thing until they're 18
years old so what the family are saying
is you knew that we informed you of that
so what's different in the nature and I
think if the BBC were to give a full
response to that claim and allegation
they need to say a little bit more than
RAC esteemed that it was a criminal we
need to know whether they actually are
refuting what the family are saying and
I don't think that we've had a direct
response to that okay what else was
asked of Tim debut on that call and what
what did he answer and what do you think
did he not answer there were lots of
interesting things that were asked and
which we did get some answers to so had
he met the presenter at the center of
this and spoken to that presenter no he
hadn't he said he was taking up a
different role overseeing it but I think
a lot of people will wonder why if this
is a high profile person this is a big
allegration that's been that's been
swirling around the BBC now for a number
of days why hasn't he sought out a
version of events for himself obviously
now he can't because he can't because
the police have told the BBC to pause he
was also asked whether the BBC had asked
for information such as phone records or
bank records to try try and follow up
their own investigation at the time that
the presenter was approached so after
the Sun article and he indicated that
that hadn't happened at this stage so it
sounds like it was a preliminary
conversation now of course he was asked
well what did the presenter say what did
they say about their relationship and
the payments and so on and so forth and
he didn't give any answer to that he
felt that that was a private matter that
there was a certain duty of care
and I think that comes back to why he
won't reveal information about what was
what came out in this first complaint
that he feels that there is a certain
level of privacy that needs to be
afforded to this person while these
matters are thrashed out and in the sun
this morning more from The Young
Person's mother and stepfather and again
this person has said through lawyers
that their mother's claims are not
correct with those claims put to Tim
Davey not really actually no one
actually brought up what the was said by
the young individual through their
lawyer but what was put to Tim Davey in
an interview on the world at one was
whether he had any information to
suggest that the uh the presenter had in
any way
been involved in paying for that young
person to have access to that lawyer do
you know categorically that the
presenter did not pay for those legal
fees because that's the suggestion being
made by the fact that is not information
that I'm party to
so you can't even say that that's no
that's not I think that's not something
for the BBC bluntly okay or whether the
presenter has been in contact with the
person at the center indeed that's
nothing that's not for the BBC there's
no suggestion I don't think anyone can
say oh that's definitely happened that
presenter has paid for those legal fees
but that's been put out there and the
director General's been unable to answer
that question
Jason stay there we'll come back to you
in a second but also in that press
briefing was Jake Cantor he's the
investigations editor for deadline and a
former media editor at the Times
now Jake you asked Tim Davey a question
as well but just tell us a bit more
about how that question process actually
worked in the meeting and how it
compared to previous annual report
briefings that you've been to yeah so I
found it quite frustrating it was a
virtual press conference and journalists
were only able to ask questions via the
chat function on Zoom this is a relic of
the pandemic the BBC has for the past
few years organized press conferences
around his annual report in his way for
very obvious reasons we were all at home
and uh it was the only way that the BBC
kids you know set out his annual report
and put up its directory General to to
speak to Media but I think
we should not be in a situation now
where that's the case particularly on a
story on a on a week where we've got
this enormous story I don't think it's
necessarily ideal for the BBC to be
vetting questions that is director
General receives and my hope is that in
the future we will move back to
in-person press conferences when the BBC
publishes its owner reports now it
should have been the day that it was
setting out its stall on the corporation
being value for money that's trusted and
it's accountable
do you think the director General stood
up to scrutiny today look Tim Davey is
good in these circumstances in terms of
handling questions from the Press he's a
pretty confident performer and that goes
right the back way back to 2012 in fact
when he was parachuted in as an
emergency director General amid the
Jimmy Savile crisis and it was during
that period that he helped study the
ship and stabilize what was an
incredibly difficult moment for the BBC
so he's got experience of dealing with
really problematic crises I think again
we saw reasonably confident display the
BBC had clearly done a lot of work to
establish this timeline
but as I say the full facts are not at
our fingers and I think it's only with
time that we'll be able to properly
reflect on how he has handled this
situation what we can say confidently is
that he didn't know about the
allegations against this presenter until
last week and that probably works in his
favor and as you say when Tim Davey was
brought in as director General his aim
was transparency
and if you look at how BBC News has
reported this story would you say
they're making efforts to be transparent
I think there are a couple of things in
play for the BBC here
um one is one is quite recent
um so
the BBC gave water wall coverage of the
Philip Schofield issue
uh it was leading bulletins they were
doing live blogs on it
and I think if it does not provide
coverage that is commensurate with the
Phillips Schofield coverage then it
opens itself up to questions about
holding other broadcasters to standards
that is not holding itself to and the
second thing is the Jimmy cyborg Scandal
you know I think that lingers long in
the memory of BBC employees and BBC
journalists and
um they uh they they have a record of
holding their own leaders to account and
I think we still see The Echoes of that
in some of the reporting that we're
seeing from the BBC today I think the
BBC I mean look I was listening to the
BBC Radio coverage and TV output there
was members of the public commenting on
this story and I think there's a real
risk that mistakes could be made the
presenter could be identified the young
person involved in this case could be
identified so the BBC does have Have To
Tread carefully I think going forward
okay let's talk about the Sun what do
you think it means for the sun there
journalistic rigor really being brought
into question over this isn't it what
steps will they have taken do you think
to check the story that the parents came
to them with was true it's very
difficult to say all we have or
certainly all I have is the son's own
reporting on this there are a few Clues
I think in its reporting it has said
more than once that the mother of this
individual has signed a sworn affidavit
so there is some sort of official
testimony potentially legal in nature
that the sun could fall back on
um if there were legal proceedings the
second thing that is made clear is that
the mother has not requested payment for
telling her story it's been at pains to
point that out in its reporting so that
suggests that there's no Financial
benefit
in the individuals blowing the whistle
on this issue but the sun is being much
more Coy about the evidence that it does
have or has seen at no point in its
reporting has it said that it has seen
bank records texts or pictures
it suggests that it may have had sight
of some of the dossier that the family
has handed to the BBC over the weekend
but we don't know the precise evidence
that the sun has and I think the
statement by The Young Person's lawyer
to BBC News uh on Monday
raises serious questions about the sun's
reporting
Jason so much has changed since we last
spoke what 24 hours ago we've had so
much more information where do you think
this leaves the BBC now
well it's got a difficult Balancing Act
and I think it was quite interesting
that the world at one presenter said to
Tim Davey in this building everybody
knows who this is which is quite a
striking thing to come from a BBC
presenter so how long can you keep this
you know Under Wraps as well without I
mean coming up publicly talking about
that it's not a sustainable situation is
it it is a very difficult and complex
situation and we're trying to calmly and
judiciously navigate our way through
quite difficult circumstances whereas I
said you've got to balance duty of care
issues privacy issues I think I would
restate that it is absolutely not the
right thing to be doing to speculate
some of the malicious stuff online I
would condemn of course I would but I as
director General have to make those
calls fairly and in a balanced manner as
we go through the process so that's one
question for the BBC but
um I think what looking at the way that
Tim Davies handling this he's he's
trying to do it in a way that he can
look back at it in a year's time or so
and say you know we got the balance
right we got the balance right between
the duty of care for that presenter uh
who is going to come under an awful lot
of scrutiny one way or another by the
police the corporation and the general
public and I think that he's already
indicating that there are lessons that
will be learned from this the flagging
system none of the senior Executives
within the BBC uh and director General
himself knew about these allegations
until they were approached by the Sun so
when the original allegations came in
they weren't told about them and was
that the right procedure when does that
information go up the chain and how high
does it go up the chain and how quickly
should it be flagged so there's lots and
lots of questions for the BBC over this
and I think you know they'll already be
asking those but they're still in the
middle of the crisis they've still got
to get it right from here in
okay Jason thank you so much for talking
to us you're welcome
this episode was produced by Rosie
Gillett Annie Joyce and Alex Eden our
editor was Paul stanworth